i think really i should have defeated
but anyway i left that to others the
weasley family is the glue that keeps
everything together in the harry potter
franchise but sometimes even they could
get into some pretty sticky situations
behind the scenes all the mischief this
family didn't manage on set made for
some pretty magical blooper binging from
rupert just not focusing to some actual
twin mayhem we've got your weasley dose
for the day
number one surprise surprise ronald
weasley can't focus
you just shut your mouth i do
just shut your mouth ron wasn't always
known to be the smartest of the group
but did rupert grint take this character
on in real life there's just way too
many corpsing and unfocused moments that
we're surprised he even got through
filming he does it all the time and
you'll ask him what will you laugh and
he goes i don't know we can't even find
the funny part of his lines to produce
so much giggling all the saris in the
world couldn't make up for this amount
of clubs and the rest of the cast just
couldn't get enough of it my grandson's
a daily prophet that's rubbish
sorry
maybe the filming days were just too
long for this weasley to fight the
sleepies
number two it ended out as a kiss but
with the awkwardness behind the scenes
how did it end up like this
everyone could sense this was going to
happen emma and rupert knew but really
kept it deep down as to not face the
inevitable outcome this was an explosive
smooch moment for the fans but for them
it just felt like incest that's the only
way
i can describe it uh
what not the answer we were hoping to
hear but why not just let it happen
anyways we wonder if director david
yates knew of the discomfort between the
actors because he really just wanted to
get a whole lot of takes of them
snocking
they weren't even aware of this rubbish
until it was far too late for them to
back out and when they found out you can
just really tell they were not looking
forward to it doing the kiss between ron
and hermione and the tweet in the
chamber of secrets number three siblings
fight yes but turning into old people
and then fighting just another explained
incident in the magical world you
muggles wouldn't understand
these troublesome twins were ready to
take on each other in the arena great
hall but was this one as believable as
the one the phelps twins would have in
real life well to director mike newell
these boys needed to step it up a notch
okay who wants to
fight but as every good director needs
to get their hands dirty it seemed to
mike that jumping in and tackling one of
them was the best idea we can't dream of
a more hilarious moment for the others
to experience on set but certainly hope
newell learned his lesson here after
injuring himself
number four this mama bear is not about
to let her kid get eaten and we'd be
confident in saying that a battle with
voldemort would be much better than
taking the flying car out for a ride and
getting yelled at by molly weasley
where have you
been
but is julie walters all like that in
real life no quite the opposite she can
even find the happiest of places in the
darkest of scenes and joke around with a
death eater in the process lovely
working with helen she's such fun
[Music]
and look at all those moves julian
plainclothes is almost unrecognizable
with her spouting imaginary spells at
her co-star looks like both witches
enjoyed this scene a lot they just both
needed to get out a little goofy energy
this moment was just too serious to jump
right into who's next
number five look out snatchers you've
got a track star in your midst i hit it
hit it at quite a pace and then just
sort of flopped over it there's no
denying that scene in deathly hallows
part one where the three are running
away from the snatchers was a really
well done chase scene but apparently it
was very difficult for rupert to slow
down as if they weren't going fast
enough to begin with emma watson
explains his newfound talent a little
more in detail like
james bond style
cartwheel over here imagine if that was
a crossover double07 takes out voldemort
you can send us a check anytime for that
idea warner brothers
number six everyone could feel the
awkward energy here and we mean everyone
this leg moves first
right
can you imagine elegantly waltzing with
an older co-star in front of all your
on-set friends we can't but if you had
any questions for anyone there at the
time we're sure they can tell you how it
was just probably not rupert he's really
trying to forget this moment to ever
happen your right hand on my waist where
on my waist we can all appreciate a
healthy dose of embarrassment behind the
scenes but what's even better is that
the phelps twins found this a great
opportunity to push grint to his utmost
uncomfortability they took this as an
opportunity to make sure grant was the
center of attention and blushing from
awkwardness at every moment now you will
have to lead eventually
understood
number 7 there was no grin from grunt
here
who doesn't love it when young actors
get a little embarrassed in the makeup
chair we can only imagine how wild it is
to be thrown into a massive production
but to get powdered up at a mere 11
years old because he doesn't like the
clip in his hair
some of us could get past a lot of
productions demands for a couple million
dollars just to get those student loans
paid off but we can totally understand a
young rupert's embarrassment when having
a camera shoved a little too close to
our faces reportedly this was the last
and only time he allowed cameras in the
makeup room totally understandable
fellow wizard it is just so adorable
though seeing a baby grin blush from
embarrassment
number eight it's all fun and games
until someone breaks a wand of course
but the good thing here is that it looks
like rupert and dan were just blowing
off some steam before work they are by
no means masters at the game they're
attempting to play but it looks like
rupert is getting the most out of this
one though we can't imagine rupert not
letting the chosen one win a few rounds
even though dan's ball passing skills
are a little rough
number nine sometimes even the best of
wizards can let go every once in a while
and a little sherry can certainly go a
long way here if any character in harry
potter deserved a little sherry it's
molly weasley not only have her and
arthur taking care of all the weasleys
but they even helped orchestrate the
fight against the dark army so why not
let julie walters have a little fun at
her own son's wedding and of course let
mark williams poke a little shade in her
direction
number 10 candy can do wonders on a
child sometimes good but more than a few
times bad hey rupert
you like those
sweet
director christopher columbus made the
unfortunate mistake of giving a young
rupert candy in the train car scene in
sorcerer's stone and it looks like he
might have shared it with dan as well
these two couldn't even keep it together
when the makeup artist was trying to
sparkle them up before takes but these
two were definitely up to something we
speculated before about this moment and
there's no denying now that the harry
potter musical was born at this moment
my name is my name is gary
number 11. a little louder for the ones
in the back
bonnie wright's only got a couple of
juicy scenes in the potter franchise
so each one had to count and things
definitely started to pick up for ginny
in order of the phoenix but when it came
time for her to bring on the alpha
quidditch captain moment she needed a
few takes for the crowd to actually hear
her please quiet please
shut it
whatever one spell thing the minister of
magic pulled at the beginning of goblet
of fire should do the trick
number 12. the chaos duo on film and on
set apparently oliver and james phelps
were notorious behind the scenes for
pulling pranks some minor and some
definitely destructive you know they
switched names on production multiple
times throughout the years of shooting
that one didn't produce any big
consequences but when the filmmakers did
they evidently had to reshoot a couple
of their scenes but the minister of all
pranks comes when the twins stole a set
construction workers walkie talkie and
decided to blow some steam between takes
in the end they got a big talking to by
the director and we can only imagine
they'd keep all walkie-talkies secured
and locked up after that
number 13. was it just us or was rupert
having a little too much fun puking up
slugs say something
[Music]
any puking or hurling sounds is a no-go
from us we can't believe how many of the
actors behind rupert were actually able
to stomach that including grint they all
looked like they had way too much fun
filming this bit the twins took no delay
in making sure ron was the center of
attention making it a complete
embarrassing moment for him we never
knew there was a right way to puke up
slugs we figure for the sake of
everyone's stomachs they could have just
done one go of it and given everyone a
much needed break
number 14 after all the countless hours
on set maybe it was a necessity for
someone to bring rupert to pinata to
smash
[Applause]
attempt to smash to be a little more
accurate here given ron's track record
with wands breaking and misspelling we
think they should have thought twice
before giving him a blunt object around
other people
number 15 come on ron you have one job i
usually read them before we start that
oh it's fine i was quite late reading
the last one if you were one of the
stars of the biggest film franchises in
the world wouldn't you jump at every
opportunity to make sure you knew what
was happening next to your character
well lo and behold the almost real-life
ron weasley actor just couldn't bring
himself to read any of the books on time
before filming i left it quite late i
was probably the last one to read it in
the world
we mean he did get around to getting
them read eventually but he really just
took the whole my name's ronald weasley
thing a bit too much into his personal
life or maybe it was just the other way
around we mentioned too many bloopers
with rupert than we'd like to count but
that doesn't mean the rest of the
weasley family's antics should be left
out so if you had to share an elevator
with one of the weasley family members
which one would you choose let us know
in the comments